Republicans are now staging ridiculous
hearings in New York City on violent
crime we have a red State murder problem
and a red City violent crime problem but
Republicans don't want you to know that
they want you to believe oh it's liberal
cities that are dangerous and that's it
it is true that in New York City in 2022
there was a violent crime rate a
homicide rate of 5.2 per hundred
thousand people whereas in Columbus Ohio
there was a homicide rate of 15.4 per
hundred thousand people the homicide
rate in 2022 was nearly three times
higher in Columbus Ohio than it was in
New York City the right-wing Narrative
of dangerous Democratic cities or states
or whatever it's absolutely and
completely bogus